The song that reminds me
of my family is,
"May the Circle Be Unbroken."
We used to sing that
on road trips.
I don't even know
what that song is.
We were a real church-family.
BRIDGET EVERETT:
I'm not much of a church person.
We went on holidays and...
when somebody died.
So, if a lot of people die,
like in rapid succession, then,
I guess, I could call myself
a "church person."
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
"Piece of My Heart"
is a song that represents
freedom to me because
when I first moved
to New York, the only chance
I was getting to sing
was at karaoke bars.
And so I would sing
"Piece of My Heart" and,
rip my shirt and,
take shots and,
you know, spit 'em out
on the people,
and it was, uh, pretty magical,
at least for me.
Oh, it was magical for everyone.
I know that for a fact.
My song that is freedom is
"You Oughta Know"
by Alanis Morissette.
That's my other karaoke song.
-Is it really?
-Yes!
-That was my karaoke song.
-Oh, my god!
And, in fact,
it's my audition song
whenever you have to
do a "pop-rock" song
for musical theater.
I'm so afraid of
expressing anger in life.
You know, it's my own block.
You get to be so angry
in that song. You get to scream.
-Feels good.
-Feels good to be angry.
-We're all hurting.
-(JEFF HILLER LAUGHS)
We're all broken.
It is like The View.
-Oh! That's him!
-Oh, god!
Get down!
I loved shooting in the car
because that was really when
-our characters, I felt like--
-Found each other.
-Kinda found each other.
-Yeah, I agree.
And it was also fun to have
sort of low-stakes stunts.
-Is driving a stunt?
-It was for me.
Don't hesitate.
BOTH: Don't hesitate.
Don't hesitate!
(TIRES SQUEALING)
I think
one of my favorite things
about this show is, like,
the sweet relationship between
Joel and Sam.
And you know when you're, like,
finding a friend
and falling in love
with your friend...
Um, that's what
the car chase allows for,
so I think
it's really very tender.
Right.